are you [ __ ] kidding me when someone
gives you a gift and you and hate it you
are supposed to be polite you're
supposed to pretend that you like it
because it's the thought that counts
so I decided to put that to the ultimate
test by giving people the worst gifts
ever I got a bunch of my co-workers
excited because I told them I was going
to give them gifts I love presents they
think they're going to get good gifts
big fan of getting presents
who doesn't love gifts when in reality I
just came up with a bunch of random
terrible gifts that I thought no person
could ever possibly want so I'm just
busy wrapping the worst gifts in the
world I've got all my gifts wrapped my
coworkers are about to come in here and
open up they're intentionally bad gifts
mmm oh my god and it's wrapped and it
has my name on it
I'm so excited I'm just gonna go for it
okay I'm just I'm sexy and I'm no man
I kind of love it like this is very me I
well I think it's a good gift for me I
[ __ ] love it
I'm nervous cuz this sounds like a box
of teeth to me I know what a box of
teeth sounds like being in front of a
camera to have to react makes me more
nervous either gross yeah I think this
is actually pretty thoughtful because
I'm prankster
maybe I'll hide one of these in my
husband's pocket like every day I think
this was a great gift okay
are you [ __ ] kidding me I just got a
picture of myself I actually really like
this picture of me I don't know maybe
I'll give it to my mom for Christmas no
she would hate this gift yeah oh my god
you just gave me trash
[Music]
you gave me old candy corn there's the
worst food known to man at least I can
pop this bubble wrap you know what I'm
gonna put it in the trash because it's
it's trash okay here we go
[Laughter]
yeah what's his name
Gretchen I love it I honestly do it's
very unique and I would have never had
this if it weren't for our friendship
it's definitely [ __ ] haunted ah my
show to you guys for I show it to myself
[Music]
I like this I really like it which one
is me
I love handmade gifts this is gonna be
my new desk art um who's actually pretty
funny present this is a this is scary
why not love it such a unique and
thoughtful present if we're gonna be
honest
this thing's scary it's gonna give me
nightmares I hate it okay
it's a big reveal it's a bunch of damn
paper clips
[Music]
I mean they serve a purpose
maybe I'll decorate my desk with them I
am so excited to open this nice it's not
something I wanted but it's something I
needed what would I use these for uh I
my tree gift them I feel so guilty that
I made up and I'm sorry candy bowl with
good candy because I feel like a dick
is this candy poison yeah I guess that
makes it okay why are you sorry I came
in here with no doll now I have a doll I
probably wish I could be this honest
every time I open a present because
people give some [ __ ] presents don't be
an [ __ ] when you receive about you
and someone put thought into it I was
really surprised how many people
actually liked they a gift or at least
pretended to multiple people said they
were jealous of the human teeth that I
gave to Chelsea Chelsea got teeth I
think the weirder the gift sometimes
that's the more fun I can only get so
many sweaters so I think it's really
thoughtful that you gave me two teeth it
really is the thought that counts and
human teeth make a better gift than I
would have thought I like getting gifts
because I like things and I'm very
materialistic
[Music]
I can't stop with Canada I need to turn
this away